i started to go through your blog
article and i got to um
fire prevention and fire insurance as
remedies to this problem so we've
already talked about the problem
um why it exists and why they're trying
to implement it
maybe i'll let you take over since
you're the expert and you wanted to
cover this topic and you wrote the blog
anyway but
um
so step two as far as a remedy with fire
insurance can you explain that to the
viewers
sure so depending on what jurisdiction
we're talking about so if we're in
canada you simply need to become a
non-resident which means that you need
to be able to live somewhere else if
you're in the in the us
you need to because they have
citizenship-based taxation you need to
have another citizenship in place
which you may have because you move to
the united states and naturalize so you
have the citizenship of your birth or
you may have the citizenship
because you had a foreign parent or you
may have moved to another country and
become naturalized there
or a lineage or a citizenship by
investment so you need to have another
citizenship in order to give up your
american
australia for example is becoming
non-resident in australia
is a bit more of a sticky wicket than
for example canada
in that you it's best that you move to a
tax treaty jurisdiction so buying a
citizenship in a
place
which doesn't have a tax treaty with
australia isn't particularly helpful
if you clearly want to leave there so
you have to look at
what are the rules in order to
escape the fire of your current taxing
jurisdiction
and do i need
simply another residence do i need
residents
in a jurisdiction with a tax treaty or
do i need another citizenship also are
you suggesting that you can retain that
residence in canada but
um abandon your citizenship and not pay
the capital gains tax if you're not a
citizen
no so canada
tax is based on residents if you sojourn
spend 183 days in canada or if you have
centralized your mode of living in
canada so giving up your canadian so if
you're a permanent resident or work
permit holder
or even a visitor who spends too much
time in canada you're going to become
tax resident
so in order to cease to become tax
resident
you need to to move
and you need to get rid of certain ties
in canada okay
so then you have to dispense with the
asset you have to sell the house
correct so so when you leave
canada it's as if you die to the
canadian tax system so it's a deemed
disposition for capital gains purposes
and the the point i was making in
the blog was right now a lot of
canadians have a lot of their wealth in
their principal residence of course they
have an exemption from capital gains on
that which they would also have when
they became non-resident
they may also have small business
exemptions etc
but what happens if in the future
they limit or they completely get rid of
the capital gains exemption on principal
residents
and you can say well that would be
political suicide
and sure if your voters were only
boomers but if you have
gin
if you have millennials who say well the
housing market is
is way out i can't afford to even rent
hardly own
but i can vote so i don't really care
that
you know
the the the boomers have to
pay capital gain on this house that they
bought for a hundred thousand which is
now worth two million
um got it um i was speculating on this
earlier before you came on but are there
other other countries that are currently
talking about
taxing capital gains at the rate that
trudeau is in canada
it's there is a a a push and a pull
countries
tend to
try to tax what i call their native
golden geese so canadian the canadian
government tries to
tax canadians
who have born raised here and who have
life inertia in canada
much more than they try to try to tax
foreigners who they are trying to
attract to their shores
and this is true in a lot of
jurisdictions
so
you can abuse your golden your native
golden geese because they're much less
they'll take a lot more abuse before
they'll fly away whereas if you want to
attract the foreign golden geese you
have to make it more attractive than the
jurisdiction that they're in so far
so if we look at for example all the
controversy that's going on right now
in the uk
that theory with regards to the
chancellor the ex-checker which would be
the equivalent in canada or the finance
minister
um his wife is something called a
non-dom
well the uk is why do all these russians
and greeks and saudis and wealthy
indians live in in the uk well because
they only get taxed on uk source income
if they're not from there so they have a
regime which has been around for a
century and a half
to attract wealthy foreigners that's why
they're all there
well now
the
it looks like you know there's a great
chance that that system may may
be thrown kind of under the bus
and
one of the problems is that if it does
um
you know where do these people go to
next
okay get a backup plan get fire
insurance and get a
you know a fire escape plan so let's
talk about the fire escape plan because
that's step three in your article and by
the way for those of you guys watching
um i drop david's um article in the live
chat so you can find it and read it
there later if you want
right so a fire escape plan is depending
on your jurisdiction
it'll show what's involved but so if we
look at canada
it's preparing for that deemed
disposition
so
one of the things i speculated i i
thought people should think about is if
you are worried that in the future
you're going to have to pay capital
gains
some or all capital gains in your
principal residence
maybe you should think about selling
that now while you have that exemption
so that you know your sales price gross
equals net
as opposed to having you know only the
net proceeds after capital gains
you can then either decide i'm going to
move now
or you can say i'm going to start
renting or i'm going to put things into
capital gain much more efficient capital
gain
vehicles so i'm going to put it into
shares which are going to grow as
opposed to to paying dividends
um so that it's a fire escape plan is
let's look at your asset by asset
how that's going to be impacted by the
departure tax in canada as we call it
also
what do i do
in
kind of
[Music]
what am i going to do with regards to
lifestyle things so this is the point
where you start to kind of declutter
your life
okay and one of the big things that
canadians always go on about is oh we
have free health care you don't have
free health care you pay a premium every
april 30th for that healthcare thank you
very much and healthcare is a commodity
that you can go and buy in the
marketplace
and when you compare
the the premium for that healthcare so
for example i live
in poland um the top
income tax rate in poland and there's no
kind of provincial uh um
version
is 19
and they're dropping that down they're
looking at dropping that down to six
percent why
poland
also has a 23 vat tax
but if i don't spend that money i don't
pay the vat they also have very high
excise taxes on everything from alcohol
to
certain commodities etc
so i've organized my life so that i
don't pay a lot of vat and i've
organized my life so i don't have a lot
of
taxable income that's even subject to
the 19
for that there is the equivalent of kind
of national health care service or
canadian
medicare
whatever we want to call a canadian
canadian version
in addition there's also private health
care
coverage which is
not only kind of
pretty good it's actually world-class
because they also have a large medical
tourism industry here
so
uh i had twins those are high-risk
births
and in the the specialists ob gyn that
we had
sitting in there were russians saudis
americans brits
because they would all come to this top
clinician
and clinic
so for my family just to give you so
there's myself my wife
and two eight-year-old twins
and we pay
in
so we have a gold-plated
medical
coverage
and
so that's 800 zloty a month divide by
four for the us dollars so for 200 bucks
that includes
dental
cosmetic surgery
everything so you're covered from head
to toe head to toe four people in our
family 200 us a month
got it so compare that to what you sent
to revenue canada last april yeah yeah
it's it's very expensive and it's a
shitty system i mean i i have an email
on my list that talks about how
they really messed up uh the beer bug
treatment with a a completely
unnecessary and toxic drug called rem
deserver so if you're on my email list
you can read about that there if you
want to know how to get on my email list
it's pinned in the top of all my videos
you can find it hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you